unity bright on 8 news now is sponsored
by our community pride partners finley
automotive group southwest medical part
of optum care and silver state schools
credit union
findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this next segment completed a 4 million
remodel of one of their dealerships to
better serve this community so we
stopped by to check it out
[Music]
findlay automotive group is all about
cars and community welcome to findlay
honda henderson cfo tyler quarter is
excited to reintroduce us to finley
honda the dealership got a tune-up after
23 years of being in business so we just
finished a big remodel and expansion of
the facility we're really excited
about the new facility here so we want
to show you that but also our longtime
general manager scott ramer recently
retired and so that gave us an
opportunity to promote one of our most
dynamic and bright young managers that
new general manager is tommy rail and
with experience in both sales and
service quarters says he's bringing new
ideas and energy to the remodel store at
the new facility obviously the finishes
are all brand new so it's bright and
fresh we've got a really cool light
fixture up above that highlights the new
vehicles in the showroom and the biggest
thing is increased capacity so that we
can serve more customers in the city
whether it be through our express
service center through our main shop or
selling new and pre-owned vehicles in
the showroom findlay honda's express
service center got a tune-up too our
previous express center was only three
bays and we've upgraded it to five bays
the expanded express lube facility gives
us the ability to serve more customers
more efficiently and more quickly the
remodel has also led to increased car
inventory for that increased customer
capacity honda has allocated us
additional new vehicles
and especially in times like this where
new car inventory is limited we've got a
definitely gotta benefit by receiving
these additional vehicles and what types
of vehicles does that include so honda
offers a wide range of vehicles we've
got hybrid vehicles
fuel efficient compact and then we've
also got some rugged off-road vehicles
in the pilot and passport and the
ridgeline and of course the family
vehicle the honda odyssey on top of that
you can enjoy the caffeination station
and marketplace while you shop or wait
that's an upgrade in customer experience
and you can't do that without investing
in your staff and in addition to our
investment in the facility in the
showroom we've also made a significant
investment this year in
staffing because along with all of these
new cars that we're selling we have
significant demand for service and
repairs so we want to make it fast and
easy and convenient so we've invested in
a significant amount of staff for our
expected summer rush we can still use a
few more technicians but other than that
we're well set up to to make sure that
our customers are taken care of working
for the finley organization is one of
the one of the best jobs in the city i
can vouch for that i've been in the car
business for a long time and the family
organization really does make a
difference finley honda henderson and
the family automotive group are great
community partners and so as the new
general manager here i plan to put a
significant emphasis on maintaining that
and also increasing our community
involvement from our dealerships level
and yes they are hiring technicians if
you're interested we want to thank again
findlay automotive group for sponsoring
that community prize segment and for
being one of our community pride
partners kendall i'll send it over to
you